I believe in the strength of the things
that I believe in and I refuse to accept
your thesis that's all
everything that could have been done
wrong has been done wrong well I don't
agree with the premise but that's my job
I don't accept that the United States
has anything like withdrawn from public
life it's heavily engaged in Europe in
Eastern Europe Central Europe in the
front line at the Ukraine its bombing
and coordinating bombing in many other
parts of the world if that's the United
States as an isolationist power I'd hate
to see them if they got on to the front
foot
neither do I accept Phil's apparent
thesis at the end they are that we are
somehow alien to Europe because we don't
speak the same language very smart
operator one of the smartest in the
world today 10 times smarter than the
American president or the British prime
minister for that matter I believe he
acts in Russia's interests and it was
not in Russia's interests to carry out
the scribble affair if the hidden point
and your question is do I support him no
I don't if I had been a Russian I
wouldn't have voted for him but I do
support many of the foreign policy
stances that he has taken particularly
in Syria where he has been instrumental
in defeating Isis and Al Qaeda and the
alphabet soup of Islamist extremism in
the Middle East which i think is
necessary but not sufficient condition
for stability peace progress in that
area
George do you think that Putin has felt
emboldened by America's not quite
withdraw from public life but you know
but Obama clearly didn't want to get
involved in any more military conflicts
I mean I get the sense that Putin
thought our great now no one's going to
oppose me in the wholly engaged in
Ukraine on Russia's front line the
Victoria Nuland former ambassador now at
the State Department told us of the
billions of dollars that she spent
subverting the power in the Ukraine John
McCain and all the other neocon Hawks
won whenever off the streets and the
coup that took place in the Maidan what
is it now
18 months ago is is the the cause of the
confrontation between US and Russia I
don't see that Putin has done anything
wrong
anywhere else he frustrated Western
policy in Syria that's true but that
wasn't wrong I don't see where this
chargesheet against Putin is drawn up
from now Russia is a capitalist country
with an elect Russia's a normal
capitalist country with run by a
kleptocracy it it is run by a
kleptocracy but not quite as
kleptocratic as the Yeltsin era which
was of course healed by right-wing
people in Britain as some kind of golden
era the reason Putin is popular in
Russia is because he's taking some of
the wealth back from the kleptocrats now
till himself I don't think it's to
himself I don't see where you're you
know respected journalists I don't know
why you would make such an assertion on
tape without the remotest piece of
evidence to support it he's saying he's
not corrupt I'm not I'm saying that he's
not taking money for himself where's the
evidence
give me your evidence he's giving Russia
that some of its perceived national
dignity that it lost under Yeltsin well
you can laugh if you like but that's how
Russians see it now my point is that's
why the protests on the streets protests
in every streets Bronwen there are
protests in London but that doesn't mean
that the majority of Russians don't
support Putin my point is I don't know
why you needed to have a confrontation
with Putin he's not my man is your man
I'm a leftist he's not if I could choose
the government of Russia
it wouldn't be Putin he's a man that
thinks like you he believes in
capitalism free markets National States
I don't know why you needed to fall out
with him that's my point
China's a different kettle of fish it
has a different ideal ideology but
Russia doesn't and the elephant in the
room the morass of the Syrian war some
of you know me from my stand against the
Iraq war I'm here to tell you that the
involvement of Western countries in the
Syrian war is the worst thing we have
ever done
ie worse than Libya worse than Iraq our
belligerent foreign policy of arming
financing propagandizing for Isis al
Qaeda and the alphabet soup of Islamist
fanaticism in Syria is the worst thing
that we have ever done and
notwithstanding that the war is almost
over we may very well be about to double
down to double our bets on the
catastrophic conflict in Syria so can a
belligerent foreign policy bring about
peace and stability in the world not
bloody likely
I mean we could all have laughed at your
assertion that
Iraq war was legal you're the last man
standing saying that it was legal I
didn't say it was a gun standing seeing
that it was I'm not that even if I were
I wouldn't be as that isn't that isn't
the point
quite the United might the United States
massacred millions of people in the
lifetime millions of people in the
lifetime of many of the people here in
Vietnam and caused the massacre of
millions more in Cambodia yet you parade
the United States some kind of lawful
benign force well that's not how it
looks from start how this sounds right
did the United States well I'm quiet and
I'll tell you both of us were very clear
in our remarks to say at the beginning
that we do not regard the United States
of America as some sort of caricature
example of perfect goodness we both were
very clear that no country is in that
position and that though there are both
there are on both sides there are things
which the United States have done of
which anyone would be proud and things
of which you would not now it is not
good enough for you to then pretend that
our view of the United States is some
sort of cartoon in which everything is
rosy and gorgeous nobody thinks that
nobody thinks anything so fundamentally
and obviously stupid will you be quiet
though the Middle East is a total
catastrophe everything that could have
been done wrong has been done wrong from
the sykes-picot fake artificial division
of the Arab countries double-dealing as
usual at the end of the first world war
ii the buttressing of tyranny throughout
the intervening period through in one
case supporting islamist fanaticism in
one country but opposing it in another
country and supporting it again in a
third country opposing it in a fourth
our policy is a total catastrophe and
libya is a very good case in point
Gaddafi
was probably the worst the most crazed
of all the Arab leaders Phil's ex boss
thought he could do business with him
and did quite successful didn't you
purchase tyranny by supporting Saddam
Hussein I'll come to Saddam Hussein if
you would like if they hadn't overthrown
Saddam Hussein there would be no Isis
and there would be no al-qaeda cascading
around the world before the Iraq the
fact there would be no Isis in Iraq
there would be no Isis in Syria now Isis
control one-third of each country but
don't let him off the hook with Libya
his former body yes your former boss was
the best of friends with Gadhafi I've
never met Gaddafi or any member of his
grisly family unlike Mr Blair I'm not
blaming Phil for that he was only the
hired hand but my point is I wasn't
gonna happen Gaddafi was a disaster
Gaddafi was a disaster it takes real
genius to make Libya 10 50 100 times
worse after Gaddafi than it was under
Gaddafi
the exceptional ization of Donald Trump
to which you've just been listening is
absurd Donald Trump's been the president
of the United States for less than two
years did the chaos in the world start
less than two years ago it's utterly
ridiculous the crooner your idol nice
suit Barack destroyed Libya and turned
it into a slave market and a jihad
market for at least seven heavily armed
different Islamist groups wasn't Trump
that did that was Obama that did that
you have the goal to pray and eat george
w bush is somehow better than donald
trump george w bush and your other hero
tony blair killed a million people in
iraq and
rising spawned Isis cascaded across the
world you see how happy how smug you are
about the rules-based society that we
had before Donald Trump 23 months ago 22
months ago where was the rules-based
order in the invasion and occupation of
Iraq and utterly illegal act the
consequences of which will still be
feeling in a hundred years from now
where was the rules based in the
destruction of Yugoslavia no
international law no United Nations
Security Council unilateral use of
Western power deployed by the people
you're trying to persuade us were better
than Donald Trump
Vietnam was leveled bombed back to the
Stone Age drowned in chemical weapons by
Richard Nixon and by Lyndon Johnson they
were a part of this rules-based
complacency of which you speak and in
aid of your argument you draw attention
to the fact that populist SAR coming to
power the populist SAR coming to power
precisely because of the failure of your
international order precisely because of
the failure of your orthodoxy it's
because neoliberal politics totally
failed in Italy that you have the
government in Italy you have ditto in
Hungary ditto the rise although it
stopped now you may have noticed that
melons wrong with whom I agree in every
particular is now the most popular
politician in France not lepen she's
gone off for psychiatric treatment
the the rise of Trump the rise of carbon
the rise of the right and the populace
in Italy are all because of the failure
of this order which you so smugly wish
to return us to I don't think it was
about foreign policy charge to be honest
the reason these populace have been so
successful is because of domestic
discontent separate foreign yes he can
he averaged voter on the doorstep who's
voting for Donald Trump is not talking
about Syria they're talking about jobs
manufactured but you're quite wrong in
fact really the reason for the rise of
the populist in Italy is why because the
country has been flooded by millions of
refugees from the wars begun by your
heroes first of all let mark defines
himself yeah first all I've spoken but
he waits as long as me already I think I
think you're both getting a very fair
crack right no I might spike him for
longer but I wasn't accusing you of
worshipping heroes that that you didn't
worship so maybe I can sort of try and
take a step back from your very powerful
rhetoric and say first of all the fact
that we can talk about breaches of the
rules-based order like what happened in
Iraq is because you called it a mistake
no it's a breach it's a million people
dead for God's sake well there was an
assassin who died of sanctions
beforehand according to people who were
criticizing it before Saddam Hussein
killed many many people I was against
the war in Iraq and I'm still against
the war in Iraq nothing has happened
over the last 15 years to change my mind
about that but I think is the very fact
that there was an order that we can
recognize that as a breach of the order
now what makes me slightly uncomfortable
about your rhetorical flourish is that
you put all of these different things
which are quite different on the same
level you know what happened in
yet nom will happen in Iraq being put on
the same level as intervening to stop
genocide in Kosovo I find strange
they're not you know not every type of
use of violence I think using violence
is always bad but sometimes it's the
least bad option
I think the second world war was
justified given what Hitler stood for I
think intervening in Kosovo was
justified in order to stop a genocide
and where lots of innocent people were
being found in Libya well I was not
particularly beum war I think with
hindsight what we can see is genocide
and Libya genocide and Qasim okay I'm
not sure exactly if everything's
genocide then it basically normalizes
the idea of genocide for me don't you
stop tossing out about the genocide once
about my family that was actually wiped
out there's no general say that costal
fight there was at Nia cleansing and
people be a small general sight well yes
thank you so you got a microphone on you
don't need to shout okay so I I do think
that it's important not to toss words
like genocide about green it's also
important not to put every single
foreign policy decision that you
disagreed with on the same level there
there is the fact that there was a
rules-based daughter means that we can
see the breaches of that order and that
is what's being destroyed and to see I I
hated George Bush he was my least
favorite American president until Donald
Trump was it was elected I was
absolutely disgusted by I wrote a whole
book against Bush's foreign policy back
in 2004 but at the same time I do think
that he was a fundamentally different
figure from Donald Trump because he
basically believed in the existence of a
rule-based order and he was pushing to
change it Donald Trump wants to blow the
whole thing up and to bring us to a
stage of Ag of Anarchy where the only
thing that matters is the law of
the jungle and where the strong decide
what happens and the weak have to do
what they tell them to do and I don't
want to live in in that world and I
think if you can't see the difference
between those two situations and you
just normalize Trump and put him into
some kind of continuum of betrayal which
goes back you know centuries like you
did beforehand and everything is
genocide and every military campaign is
equally bad then it's impossible to have
a serious discussion about what we're
trying to do in this world I do think
that they've been all sorts of mistakes
made over the last few decades I'm a
social democrat I'm not a neoliberal I
think that a lot of these populist
parties are coming to to power because
of a failure of domestic politics I
think some of the leaders like Jeremy
Corbyn are there because the failures of
foreign policy there would be no Corbin
if there hadn't been an Iraq war that is
clear to me but I think it is important
to try and hang on to what what matters
in these things because if you're not
you end up in a kind of nihilistic place
like where everything is equally bad and
where the solution is where you just
sort of have nothing constructive to say
about anything because everyone is a war
criminal everyone is equally evil
everyone is is it's kind of genocide or
and that completely undermines any
critique that we have of what's
happening at the moment which I think
it's really worrying and scary and needs
to be stopped
we cannot hope to think that Europe can
somehow be isolated from the world in in
that sense people are moving capital is
always moving the world economy is
deeply integrated now so the notion that
we can somehow withdraw and and think
that we can live our own little life
behind fortress Europe again and not
true it's not true politically it's not
true diplomatically it's not true in the
sense that there are those people who
want to do is harm from time to time the
world is so deeply enmeshed that the
idea that we can be isolationist I think
is a fallacy something we've lost and I
never quite understand George where you
end up with your view you take all of
your view does it not lead to a kind of
isolation this position as sort of quiet
ISM and I don't say that as a in order
to be critical and usage any inquiry
that isn't that the implication that the
the the best response if actually we
take all of your views is no response at
all is to let the world be as it is
where it is and for us to remain within
our boundaries quietly that getting on
with our life now I'm not I'm asking you
what that's the opposition not
attributing it to you but but if it is
that just that doesn't seem realistic in
this world we live in
well of course this session is not about
me or about my views if you would like
me to I will of course say actually
nothing could be further from the truth
I'm not a pacifist very far from it I
believe we have to defend ourselves I
think that the choice of a new
generation of nuclear weapons and the
submarines to platform them is a very
bad choice in defense terms I believe
that we should defend our borders we
should defend our European borders we
should defend our British borders we
should organize ourselves so that our
states and our state's collection of
states are a far more successful
Enterprise than they than they currently
are
we have interests elsewhere if anyone
threatens our interests we have a right
to defend them but that's not what we've
been doing when you go halfway around
the world to invade another country and
overthrow its government on a tower of
lies you're not defending your interest
you are imperiling your interests as
everyone from the former head of mi5 to
most sentient beings in the land have
already concluded that we actually
damaged our own interests by invading
and occupying Iraq and it's not finished
yet not by a long chalk so you asked me
what I would do I wouldn't do what you
have already done what you and the
people that you supported have already
done and I said so at the time the last
conversation I ever had with mr. Blair
was this
to fall of Baghdad two weeks before the
war the fall of Baghdad will not be the
beginning of the end
merely the end of the beginning number
two there are no al-qaeda in Iraq but if
you and Bush invade and occupy it there
will be hundreds of thousands of our
Qaida and not just in Iraq but in our
own countries and I was right I mean at
least have the grace to acknowledge that
I was right and he was wrong it's not
I'm passionately denouncing the
rules-based international order I'm
passionately denouncing the fact that
there is no rules-based international
order you just called lawlessness a
rules-based international order with
some mistakes some breaches but how many
breaches does it take to invalidate your
thesis in the first place if you have
what you call an international rules
based system in the world which is not
just reached not just mistakes but which
kills millions of people and renders the
whole world completely unstable how many
times does that need to happen before
your thesis is invalidated now for most
people it long ago ceased to be credible
to call it a rules-based international
order and I refuse to accept your thesis
that's all I have not got a thesis I'm
just asking you to what you think well
you think this is that there is an
international rules-based all I see and
and and my case is that it's abundantly
clear that there has not been and that
therefore attempts to exceptional eyes
Trump which is the liberal mantra and
nonsense he's only been in 23 months so
if we have the world was in total chaos
before he came so so if we hadn't had
the United Nations and NATO set up after
the Second World War
do you think the world would have been a
better place
no because I believe in a United Nations
with real authority but as long as you
have veto powers it cannot possibly
guarantee international order
I support the United Nations it's it's
Tony Blair and George W Bush that walked
out of the United Nations and caused the
Cataclysm which is being I think
underappreciated here of the Iraq war
not since the first world war did we
take a decision that would so change the
world as the decision to invade Iraq
[Music]
George are you a narcissist do you think
in your politics no but I do think that
that charisma leadership qualities are
very important
I do have it's not self belief it's its
belief in what I believe in I'm well
aware of my shortcomings and weaknesses
and so on but I believe in the strength
of the things that I believe in and I
believe that those things are more
powerful than there are adversaries as
ideas so I'm very confident now as I
alluded earlier I went to a state school
and left very early never went to
university but now I speak every year
the Oxford Union and the Cambridge Union
and I speaker when she started Eton and
all these fancy schools very very
expensive schools what's the main
difference I see in the children from
these schools and these universities and
the children with whom I grew up his
confidence these children their parents
are getting what they're paying for
these children believe that they are the
answer that they have at least the right
to address political figures of some
standing and length and so on as equals
I've seen boys at the Oxford Union
address the foreign secretary as if they
were peers and yet one is a 19 year old
Oxford student and the other is the
foreign secretary and I see nothing
wrong with that and I know why their
parents are paying for that because if
your child or by projection your
politician your leader has no confidence
and why should you have confidence in
them I mean it seems to me there's a
there's a necessary tension of course
between such confidence and democracy
the danger of echo being the only voice
that you hear there's a tension between
these two things but both are necessary
the Democratic restraint and sounding
board but but the confidence and the
charisma is also necessary otherwise you
have mediocrity and I think that Britain
has been ruled by mediocrity for quite
some time so just to take it back then
to the leaders that we were talking
about earlier the narcissistic leader
then is that the leader that's more
likely to lead you into danger to lead
you into war because they're not hearing
other voices because of that self belief
because of that sort of not thinking
about other people perhaps undoubtedly I
think although George W Bush was
completely unnoticed ik and
uncharismatic imbecilic
heard about him was that he was the guy
that everybody wanted to have around to
their barbecue that was the kind of
thermoses well I don't know how low your
standards would be to one Charles W Bush
in your barbecue so I mean it's neither
one thing nor the other I think that's
why that's what we're coming down to
here in this discussion you can be a
narcissistic disaster like Blair or it
could be a narcissistic hero like Chacho
and if not for he we'd be conducting
this meeting in German and so it's
neither one thing nor the other
for me it's up to a point but no father
it's with checks and balances and in a
democracy you ought to have those and
you ought to have them on a daily basis
by a proper inquiring investigative and
independent impartial media which we
have entirely lacked Tony Blair led us
all over a cliff because the Parliament
became a rubber stamp and the media
became an echo chamber and therefore the
the narcissism had disastrous
consequences if these checks and
balances had been available that
narcissism would have been would have
been checked your tongue as they
understand it is to say that most
politicians alliance to do or hypocrites
and nothing against your criticise you
mr. Blair particularly on the Iraq
I'm not against wrestling me Iraq war at
all shared the same view but I think to
chance it suggests that all politicians
or most politicians are liars and
hypocrites is a terribly dangerous thing
to say and I don't believe in one mode
it'd be true well it would be dangerous
if it were untrue I've got the vast
majority of people in the country
already know that it's true because
everybody's well MPs were fund by the
Daily Telegraph's artful acquisition of
a CD to be in their hundreds hundreds
more than five hundreds out of six
hundred and fifty looting the public
purse in fraudulent expenses claims it's
a fact you might think it's an
uncomfortable truth to bring up again
there are people sitting in the British
Cabinet flipping their residences from
their constituencies to London and back
again to avoid taxation they ought to be
in prison instead of still sitting in
hours of Commons which is where most of
them are still sitting it was the period
that we've been discussing tonight where
politicians were found to be I believe
lying you believe merely foolish lying
and
MPs followed them into the lobbies in
their hundreds it's that which is
discredited the British political system
it can be dated to the Iraq war forward
by the expenses scandal and one
institution after another of ours banks
police the medium Parliament have all
been found surely to be absolutely
wanted and that's the reason there's no
credibility in the political system not
because I'm saying so the public already
noticed there's all sorts of people
desperately trying to achieve things and
failing because they're not very good at
it and that's much more important in
every profession I've ever been in
there's much more cock-up than there is
conspiracy I went from one politics
where every journalist thought that
there was this fantastic thing going on
in politics whether it alls managed to
stitch it up and they were carrying out
this malign plan with brilliant
efficiency and then I go to journalism
and I discover that all the journalists
think that politicians have got this
maligned plan which they're carrying out
with brilliant authority and everybody
thinks everybody else is really good at
something nefarious the truth is the
news desk is full of incompetence and
the politics has followed incompetence
we're all mildly doing our best and that
is a clearer description of quality
George Galloway rule politicians are
trying to do their best
I really don't buy it it may once have
been true but it is no longer and the
current Parliament what Shirley
described as democracy has brought us to
this past that we are in the current
Parliament parliamentarians political
class has led us over the precipice
towards economic ruin our society is
atomized more divided than it was when
Charles Dickens wrote Oliver Twist
that's official
we're in wars all over the world and
threatening others people are trying to
kill us and sometimes as in bullets last
week succeeding we're in very very deep
trouble because of the political class
that we have the idea the very words
assisted dying assisted suicide chilled
me to the bone for a number of reasons
first the Lord has set his cannon
against self slaughter
as Shakespeare opined in Hamlet and
that's the reason why the major
religions are against this idea but I
shan't dwell on that I don't know how
religious the audience is I'm going to
guess not very so I'm going to go on to
other arguments this road that you're
being invited to pave will lead to a
kind of fascism which will be just about
as a sci-fi nightmare for the human race
I'll tell you what will happen all
people will begin to think and be
encouraged implicitly or explicitly
encouraged to think that they are quote
past their sell-by date nobody could be
less past their sell-by date the new
doctor your wisdom your experience your
communicative ability all the training
and education that you've had what do
you mean past your cell by date no one's
past
sell-by date everyone's grandmother
grandfather has something to teach us
until the last but old people will be
encouraged to think that they have
become a burden on a capitalist society
which can make no more profit from them
and which can see only a long bill along
invoice for their health care for their
personal here will never again make
profit from them though made plenty in
the past no doubt will calculate that
when a man becomes eighty to what do we
have another eight years of him costing
us money let's try and imbue him and
others with the idea that he should
shuffle off this mortal coil and then
there's the unscrupulous relative we've
all known them and blessed I hope not to
have them but who knows as they look at
the house you're under occupying as they
view the holiday home that would be nice
to flog and go off on a world cruise on
that is not about time you thought about
assisted suicide assisted dying you can
laugh but there are many in many cases
end up in the criminal courts of people
who even killed their relatives and
encourage others collaborate with others
to kill their relatives in order to
inherit that which is theirs but which
one day upon their death could be theirs
the state I've talked about capitalist
society let me talk about the state
which is crumbling which cannot pay its
bills and within which the National
Health Service is just about the biggest
bill of them all it would be a powerful
argument wouldn't it all this bed
blocking all these chronically sick
people who are never going to get better
parenthesis unless some new medicine or
some new medical practice comes along in
which case they might get an extension
but that alone it cost us even more the
idea that the state will not inherently
if not explicitly be interested in an
idea that medically cleanses the
chronically sick wards medically
cleanses the granny farms and for AP
homes and the rest how do you think it
is possible to square those things or is
it a sense of the mission that it can't
be done you can't have equality for all
and the promotion of individual
interests well for example I voted for
gay marriage there are millions of
people in Britain against gay marriage
they have interests and they're finning
to find their expression in the right
wing of the conservative party and maybe
the conservative party will break up in
part over these kind of issues there's
nothing wrong with that
people are entitled to be against gay
marriage and they're entitled to have
politicians speaking against gay
marriage I'm in favor of it and speak in
favor of it and by the way as a an
ethnic grievance party not a single
person neither a single voter nor a
single member has complained about my
vote for gay marriage so you see these
kind of caricatures of people are
pernicious in the extreme and that's why
I get so cross about them and every one
of us is different Sean
I hate alcohol I hate gambling I'm white
with blue eyes who was brought up as an
Irish Catholic immigrant now what's my
identity when I see people rolling drunk
down soccer Hall Street or maybe even
here on why seem to be drinking a lot
during the day here I hate it I hate to
see people drinking alcohol I cannot
bear to see gambling adverts
everywhere on buses on television and so
on introduced by Tony Blair by the way
and Gordon Brown for that matter the
inventor of the Super Casino so you see
my point we all have I don't have the
same culture as David culture is not
about color or where you come from it's
about your beliefs
that's what your culture is and I have
far more in common with somebody who
believes like me from China than I do
from Britain I reject the idea that
there is a British culture there are
many British cultures you asked Mary Ann
about Trump and his foreign policy let's
review it
Trump has unilaterally withdrawn from
the Iran nuclear deal signed Salomon
binding by his predecessor and the
permanent 5+1 and the Islamic Republic
of Iran and impeccably I'm using the
words of the IAEA impeccably observed by
Iran Trump has unilaterally withdrawn
from it begun a raft of ever deep and
punishing economic sanctions against
Iran and yesterday a major terrorist
atrocity was carried out by Saudi
sponsored which means American sponsored
terrorists in hours in Iran which killed
26 people now not just soldiers but old
soldiers paraplegic soldiers members of
the public in the crowd and journalists
covering the event we are headed
potentially to cataclysmic conflict
again in the Middle East what could
possibly go wrong
Iran will undoubtedly respond
and extremely violently against Saudi
Arabia at any minute
certainly not long delete that will be
get a response and so the spiral towards
war will twist for more debates talks
and interviews subscribe today to the
Institute's arson ideas her IAI TV
[Music]